foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalist Jordan if you cut to
the wide shot you'll see there is a
gaping void in our podcast
TK Coleman has been in the hospital for
the last few days uh hopefully he'll be
back next week there was um an
intestinal blockage
um it is true that he is full of crap
too soon too soon no he's doing much
better yeah he is doing better we're
looking forward to having him back on
the podcast soon you can reach out to
him on a Twitter or Instagram we'll put
a link to both handles in the show notes
if you want to tell him to get well soon
thoughts and prayers whatever else you
want to send his way the lovely laugh
that you hear in the background of
course is from Alabama she's here today
hi everybody we've got the rest of our
team here in the studio as well and
coming up today on this free public
minimal episode we're talking into a
listener about identity clutter and the
false self we have another question
about dealing with resentment and
letting go of all that resentment that
builds up inside then we've got our
lightning round segment a live stream
question for you and a listener tip you
can check out the full two hour maximal
edition of episode 396 where we answer
five times the questions and we dive
deep into several simple living segments
that private podcast episode is out
right now at patreon your support keeps
our podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck by the way if you're
on the fence patreon is now offering
free trials so if you'd like to test
drive the minimalist private podcast you
can join our most popular tier for seven
days for free go in there download as
many episodes as you want check out the
minimalist private podcast try it out
now it is time to check out the private
podcast just visit patreon.com slash the
minimalist or click the link in the
description to subscribe and get your
personal link link so that our weekly
maximal episodes play in your favorite
podcast app you'll also gain access to
all of our podcast archives over there
on patreon all the way back to episode
zero zero one let's start with our
callers if you have a question or
comment for our show give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice recording
to podcast at the minimalists.com our
first question today is from Chelsea my
name is Chelsea I am a patreon
subscriber and I am so pumped to hear
your discussion on identity clutter this
topic has been a constant struggle for
me for as long as I can remember and
while I imagine it manifests for people
in many different ways for me it has
largely been linked to how deeply I
associate my identity with what I do for
work
while my aidish careers in 15 years have
taught me some Irreplaceable life
lessons
they have also left me feeling like a
jack of all trades but a master of none
which in my mind means jack of all
identities but a master of none
for context I have been a bartender a
Peace Corps volunteer a touring
equestrian artist an academic studying
Environmental Policy a dog walker an oil
painter and I recently got my EMT
certification because I think I would
like to help people
so with that in mind what can I do in
practice to let go of the notion that
what I do is not the same as who I am
and is it possible to pursue multiple
interests without them feeling mutually
exclusive
this is a fascinating question Chelsea
by the way you have a lovely voice you
could do voice over work what's up
Alabama would be out of business there's
plenty to go around
so Chelsea if you're ever looking to to
be a fourth fifth mic in the studio you
just let us know are you trying to give
her another thing too that's the joke
this was so relatable though because
I've I've done wide range of jobs like
she has I know how she feels yeah and
what happens here this is identity
clutter in a way in fact we did an
episode about identity clutter it's
episode 320. we'll put a link to that in
the show notes but I'm going to talk
about some things that we didn't talk
about that in that episode at all and so
there are a few ways we can go with this
I think about the first line from our
second book Ryan it's called Everything
That Remains the line of that is our
identities are shaped by the costumes we
wear and I meant that literally and
figuratively Now Chelsea you're wearing
a bunch of costumes quite literally like
if you're going to be an EMT there's a
costume you have to wear and yes those
things can be essential for doing the
work that you're going to do or showing
that I am an EMT because if an EMT shows
up somewhere and they're just wearing
like distressed jeans and like a a
sleeveless a tank top or whatever you're
gonna be like wait you're an EMT the
part of the costume is important but you
are not that costume and the thing that
I've had to remind myself over and over
and I think
most people don't know who they are and
I know some of you need to hear this you
are not your age
you are not your name you're not your
career you're not your job title you're
not your clothes you're not your phone
you are not your car
you're not your material possessions
you're not your house you're not your
furniture
you're not your relationship
you're not your haircut
you're not even your body what did Tyler
Durden say you were not your khakis
right yeah in Fight Club so it doesn't
matter what you accomplish
or what you get
the essence of you the real you is none
of these things
and these false assumptions make you
feel incomplete they keep you pursuing
more just for the sake of more more more
when you already have enough and you may
even have more than enough and that's
where the identity clutter comes into
play yeah man that was one of the first
ones uh you are not your name yeah yeah
because I'm like I don't know who I am I
mean I know what I like to do I know
what I'm passionate about I know
um what I don't like to do but if
someone was to ask me like hey Ryan
Nicodemus who are you I would just give
that answer that you gave to uh that gal
at one of our Live Events she asked you
so who are you now and you said I am
what I desire
and uh it was kind of an esoteric
response but it really makes a lot of
sense it's it's interesting because this
this had my brain going somewhere too
with
um living a purpose living my purpose or
living a purpose but I was uh having
lunch with uh a friend yesterday and I
was um talking about how I used to think
of purpose as a possession and how um
where's my purpose Melbourne has his
purpose Danny unknown Danny unsure
Danny unamused uh he has his purpose
where's my purpose you know Mallory has
her purpose and uh I was explaining how
I realized that you don't really possess
a purpose like you you can choose a
purpose to serve
and then if you serve it well enough and
dedicate yourself to it uh it will own
you yeah there isn't a vending machine
full of purpose right exactly and and he
he said something to me that I was like
oh like he took it a step further he was
like I would just append what you're
saying with this
um
you are your purpose like you are you
are your living purpose
and so basically encouraging me to stop
thinking as a uh thinking about it as a
external thing
um and I kind of like that thought so
it's like now when you're talking about
identity I think oh like in a perfect
world like I would be my living purpose
and people would look at me and and I
wouldn't even have to tell them who I am
because I'm living that purpose yeah and
all of the accoutrements of your purpose
the costumes you wear both literally and
figuratively it goes back to that line
you your identity is shaped by those
costumes but really it's shaped by the
story you tell yourself and the story
can be that here's my job title so
that's who I am here's my name so that's
who I am this is my haircut or my age or
my car and all of these things there's
nothing wrong with them it doesn't mean
you have to run around naked with no job
title No Name you have to shed all of
those things but you are not actually
those things Jed McKenna talks about the
ego being the false self oh yeah and
that's ultimately what we're talking
about here any self that I create
through these stories through the
language that I use to describe myself
is merely an approximation when Anthony
Demello talks about how you can't talk
about what is true you can only talk
about what is not true and that sort of
points toward the truth it seems that is
true also for the self because yes I
could say Ryan is a minimalist who is
Ryan Nicodemus well he has blue eyes
he's a minimalist he's five foot eleven
and three quarters
and whatever like I could describe
edit that out Sean
all right I could describe You by
listening 20 characteristics or 40
characters characteristics but that's
probably describing dozens or hundreds
or thousands of other people as well
that's not who you are and ultimately
when you get down to it there is no
separate self and now we get a bit
esoteric here when we talk about the
self and how there isn't the non-dual
approach is like well there isn't really
Orion and a Josh we're all part of this
one thing right you didn't come into
this world you came out of it as Alan
Watts says oh well I like that and what
that shows you is yeah you're not
actually different there's like a wave
right yeah when you go to the ocean you
see a wave where does it begin and where
does it end yeah it's yeah because it
doesn't end and it doesn't begin it's
all part of some larger thing and I
could capture the wave and say well this
is my individual wave and I can start
telling stories about the wave and I
could give a job title to the wave and
I've named the wave and now I've held on
to it for seven years so this wave is
seven years old I saw the this ancient
Native American Parable that said if you
didn't know your age
how old would you be yeah
are duh sorry to answer that I do feel
27 uh maybe I feel 28 at this point
right but even that is you're naming an
age so oh right I see what you're saying
if you didn't have an age how old would
you be yeah and I I contrast that with
some of the great Mystics who talk about
most adults are just 12 year olds with
59 years of experience or whatever most
71 year olds are 12 year olds with 59
years of experience because what we do
is we never really mature into adulthood
be well why is that because we've picked
up this full self we've picked up this
ego this identity whatever you want to
call it and now that is me and I feel
like I've solidified me as a person but
of course what do we really know that
the only thing that is inevitable is
change yeah because death is a type of
change your job will change your age
will change your career over a long haul
will change change your interest your
hobbies will change your friends and
relationships will change and what do we
try to do we go around I've got all
these problems I need to fix them well
that is a misnomer because you can't fix
anything because as soon as something
becomes fixed it is bound to change
otherwise you're going to stay stuck in
the old as opposed to embracing whatever
the new thing is in your life embracing
that change so how do you how do you
feel about that question like if I was
to ask you hey Melbourne like who are
you um like how would you answer that
without answering it with a question but
I love the question the answer that I
gave extraneously there we are what we
desire and the question then becomes
what do you actually desire what what is
the blueprint of your desire what is the
makeup of your desires are they memetic
desires and I think sometimes a memetic
desire can be helpful if you truly don't
know what it means to live a meaningful
life what is my purpose we're asking
that sort of question yeah now I don't
think you can go to a vending machine
and find a purpose but I think you can
survey the landscape and you can find
some people where you're like okay I
really like their sense of Joy their
sense of calm their sense of Peace what
are their relationships look like yeah
what is their career path look like what
what is it what does their life look
like how is it organized not because I
need to follow that as a specific recipe
but because wow I like that ingredient
in their life let me reverse engineer
that to see if CC whether it applies to
my life or to see whether or not maybe
that would just be identity clutter for
me yeah Alabama if I asked you who who
are you like what would how would you
answer that honestly I don't know
because it changes constantly yeah and I
don't think that's a bad thing because
I'm changing constantly my ideas my
interests my passions even talking to
Jordan I was like oh I'm into this new
thing now and he's like oh oh okay I
it's it's such a tough question this
idea and this concept of who are you and
what do you believe is not a simple
question to answer or it's not an easy
one at least let me tell you why it's so
difficult for me to even grasp a
a Ryan Nicodemus in this one United
being that can say you know who he is
um first off when I talk about my hand
it's this is me but I don't talk about
it like that right this is It's a
possession it's some but who possesses
it you know what I'm saying there is no
possessor of the hand ultimately yeah
exactly and then um the Ecker totally
the power now the the beginning of his
book where he talked about how he was
contemplating suicide because he did not
like the person that he saw
and all of a sudden it hit him like he's
looking in the mirror and he's like wait
a minute like there are two selfs going
on right now there is like the man that
I am and then there's the man who is
judging the man that I am and when I
think of those types of Concepts it's
like
there is no self right yeah and I think
it's evident when you don't
anthropomorphize it and you take it to
the more material world like if I go to
your car your Toyota Ryan or let's say
we take your Toyota from our first
documentary yes that 2004 Toyota Corolla
and you would look at that and you say
that is a car right that's a great label
for that and it makes sense to describe
it we were driving around in Ryan's car
now if I take the tires off of it you
still call it a car I guess it doesn't
do what a car needs to do oh yeah okay
you can put the tires back on but I take
the engine out is it still a car I don't
know it's like what what point does it
stop becoming a car right yeah or I put
the engine back in I just take the hood
off it's still a car but it looks less
like a car than it did but it functions
more like a car and the same is true
enough I cut your hand off or you still
Ryan Nicodemus I can't handle this
conversation
it's a tough one and by the way if I
take one of your kidneys out you're
still Ryan Nicodemus you still live I
could take 7 8 of your liver out like
what happened with Clint Ober and you
were still Ryan Nicodemus if I take one
of your eyes out of your head you're
still Ryan Nicodemus right but are you
still the same person is there a self
ultimately the answer to that is no
there is no self behind your eyes it
just it really feels that way and it's
the gift and the curse we've been given
the five senses they're way more than
five senses but the the five main senses
we always talk about those make us feel
like an individual self that is separate
we've authorized ourselves from the
world and so no wonder when we get on
social media and we amplify the self
what happens more other Rising I'm
better than you I'm different from you I
know more than you I have more
information I have more knowledge I'm
more virtuous I'm more ethical I'm more
moral
than you I am better because I am
different when we step back and realize
there isn't a self
there isn't a true self and this is hard
to really grasp it's the reason that
people often do psychedelics and things
like that so they can remove the the
self they can remove the ego the the ego
will dissolve when that happens there
are other ways to do that as well
through meditation through contemplative
exercises as well but you begin to
realize that oh I'm not all of these
stories that I tell myself and by the
way
ultimately you do become the stories you
tell yourself but here's the good news
Chelsea you can tell yourself a
different story that is much more power
empowering a story that is much more
well you can tell yourself a story that
is much more empowering but also less
limiting because it is true that you
become what you believe about the world
the stories you tell yourself about the
world absolutely Chelsea I'd love to
send you a copy of our book everything
that remains coming up on the 10 year
anniversary of that right now it's
really a book about letting go of
identity clutter specifically our career
identities Ryan and I walked away from
the corporate world at the sort of
Pinnacle of our success and everything
was awesome except everything wasn't
awesome yeah and we realized that like I
couldn't keep telling myself this lie so
if you enjoyed the podcast I think
you'll enjoy the audiobook version of
everything that remains or if you want
the book book or the ebook version we'd
be happy to send those to you as well
let's move on to some social media
questions Alexa from Instagram has
something for us I just lost a law trial
with salary rights from a big firm that
destroyed my pension and any
compensation for unused holiday pay the
world feels fake and like we are not
free how do you declutter emotional
resentment
you are right we are not free but the
prison that we create for ourselves is
often built by ourselves the prison that
you've created is built with bricks that
you formed out of your own expectations
now I will tell you this about
resentment I've dealt with a lot of
resentment in my life and
resentment is a consequence of clinging
to the way that you wish things were
yeah I wish I was taller I wish I was
prettier I wish I was richer I wish I
was smarter I wish this person treated
me this way I wish I would have gotten
that job I wish wish I've wished all
over myself and of course I have all of
this resentment now because I'm holding
on to the way I wish things were and
that's just another story that I'm
telling myself right I'm telling myself
a story that oh everything would be
perfect if blank yeah if blank then life
is awesome guess what though that's an
if then statement just remove the first
clause and it's still true if I make a
million dollars my life will be awesome
how about this
my life will be awesome and if I make a
million dollars great and if not my life
will still be awesome no Alexa that is
like
gut wrenching I mean you're working hard
you are saving up for retirement
you're being told to expect something so
that's why you have the expectation and
then they swept the rug out from
underneath of you that is um I I could
not imagine having to go through
something like that I don't know how old
Alexa is but if she's you know at
retirement age this is a big freaking
deal yeah you're right so man the only
thing that the only observation I have
here is that
don't
well you can do whatever you want but I
would encourage you to not let this
Define you because if you let this
happenstance Define you
um you now your identity is wrapped up
in being a victim yes and I'm not saying
you aren't a victim of this particular
situation but that doesn't mean you have
to live the less the rest of your life
as a victim you've been victimized you
don't need to be a victim yeah right and
you don't need to victimize others
because that's something that people do
too when they become victims especially
when they hold on to resentment right
yeah exactly exactly so uh yeah again
like this is not something that you can
just
um get over with Josh and I making
observations but
once the healing does start to um
progress you know it's it's about
finding out how you're going to move
forward because
if you don't start moving forward you're
just going to be stuck in the past and
the past is going to it's going to drag
you down being that victim the story of
the past too it should have turned out
this way and it didn't and so now I'm
stuck here one of life's most mature
virtues is a willingness to walk away
yeah walk away from anything my wife and
I just re-watched the movie Heat
recently she had never seen it and it
holds up surprisingly well Jordan or if
you're a big Heat fan I assume right
Michael Mann the cinematography I'm sure
you enjoyed the film anyway there's a
line in the film that occurs twice
actually and then it happens another
time uh without him saying it but the
main character who's essentially the bad
guy Robert De Niro although he's one of
those sympathetic bad guys like Tony
Soprano or something we we identify with
him and it's one of those cases where we
want the bad guy to win essentially
right there's a line in the film where
he says never bring anything into your
life that you're not willing to walk
away from in 30 seconds flat
now I don't take that literally yeah but
I do apply that same principle and I
have applied that principle to my life
for the last Dozen Years I'm willing to
walk away from any of it and that's
where the real Freedom comes from and so
when Alexa says you feel like you're not
free and the world is fake right yeah
you're not free
but you can Free Yourself by being
willing to walk away it doesn't mean you
have to walk away from everything but
even with my marriage my wife and I talk
about this all the time is this still
something that you want to be in well
why do we ask that question because we
don't want either one of us to be in the
relationship out of obligation yeah and
I think the same is true with a career
are you willing to walk away doesn't
mean you have to walk away from your
clothing am I willing to walk away from
this style of dress from any of your
kitchen utensils and appliances can I
walk away from these things no I used to
give value from them though but I still
don't I don't give value from anymore
okay I'm willing to walk away what are
you willing to walk away from and the
more things you're willing to walk away
from the Freer you become it really is a
superpower being able to walk away from
anything I would have penned that that
line he says don't bring anything into
your life that you're not willing to
walk away from in 30 seconds I would say
um don't become attached to anything
yeah that you're not willing to walk
away from in 30 seconds yeah yeah yeah
and and so that's what happens we often
bring something in our life and doesn't
become a problem until we get attached
to it right exactly because if you're
not attached to the thing then by
definition you're willing to walk away
from it right and attachment is the sort
of first step in clinging and so when
you get attached to something nothing
wrong with that but if you're willing to
let it go wonderful if you're not
willing to let it go then you're going
to hold on to it well into its
obsolescence and that can be an obsolete
relationship it could be an obsolete
career an obsolete ideology anything
that's obsolete for you that's no longer
serving you it's now just getting in the
way it's turned into clutter Ryan what
time is it you know what time it is it's
time for the lightning round where we
answer your questions from Tick Tock yes
indeed you can follow the minimalists on
Tick Tock Instagram Facebook and Twitter
at the minimalist during the lightning
round we each have 60 seconds to answer
your questions with a short shareable
less than 140 character response so put
the text to these minimal maxims in the
show notes over the minimalists.com so
you can copy and share our pithy answers
on social media if you'd like looks like
we have a question today from I just
don't understand how do I get the rest
of my family to at least try minimalism
I donate sell and throw away so much but
no one else is willing to give it a shot
I think you should probably just shame
them until they figure it out next
question
I isolate them make them feel bad about
themselves write in a question to the
minimalists and have them roast them on
on their podcast yeah listen hey if if
you're one of I just don't understand
family members how dare you yeah right
how dare you not be a minimalist we know
this is the only appropriate way to live
our lives and you're actually doing it
wrong and I think as soon as you
understand that I just don't understand
is doing it right
you'll be able to hop up on the pedestal
with them oh my goodness oh this is
beyond our 60 seconds let's put 60
seconds on the clock for my good friend
Ryan Nicodemus Ryan you got something
pithy for us I do expectations are the
Bedrock for disappointment and let me
just tell you I have had so many
expectations in my life expectations of
how my parents should have been
expectations about how my job should
have went how my boss should have been
expectations about how my family members
should treat me expectations about how
my business partner should treat me
expectations about how all of the people
who work with us how they should act and
let me tell you the more expectations
you have the more disappointment you're
going to have in your life and I'll tell
you when I let go of all those
expectations I cannot tell you how
freeing it was because when you lower
your expectations while keeping your
standards High magic happens I love that
let me just expand on that real quick
the expectations versus standards so
expectations is you should do this you
should do this you should do this I need
you to do this quite often we don't even
communicate our expectations which is a
problem too like I expect Ryan to do
this although I never even told him so
now I'm punishing myself twice Ryan
didn't do it I didn't tell him to do it
but even then having the expectation
even if I do tell you to do it and then
you don't meet it well now I'm beating
myself up for something you didn't do
how weird is that now a standard is for
me you know I get up every morning and I
do these three things I write read and
exercise that's my standard for me now
if Ryan came to me I said Josh I think
you should get up every morning and
write read and exercise at first I'll
say I'm already doing that but also like
how dare you tell me how I should live
my life right right yeah because you
could come to me and say Josh I think
every morning you should stop reading
and why do you have that expectation of
me right yeah but give me 60 seconds
real quick I want to give you something
pithy and maybe we can expand on it
together
the process is only as compelling as its
benefits quite often we get really
excited about something I'm excited
about decluttering I'm excited about
minimalism I'm excited about this new
fashion trend or this new social media
app I'm so excited about this you should
do it too let me show you how
no one cares how to do it if they don't
understand the benefits they have to
understand the why so what's the most
compelling way to convince someone that
minimalism is appropriate for them is to
not convince them at all but simply show
them the benefits in your life and then
also show them how their life might be
better with less how their life might be
more with less what are the benefits of
simplifying your life and what are the
benefits of simplifying their life then
they'll feel compelled to let go yeah
yeah I mean I I just don't understand
this question here um well let me point
this out their standards are that they
donate they sell they get rid of as much
as they can they live a very
minimalistic lifestyle that's a high
standard but even if those benefits that
they experience isn't translating to
their family like that has nothing to do
with the standards right yeah yeah and
so I think you go even further here I
donate I sell and I throw away so much
they're seeing the how to that's not
compelling at all I don't it's boring to
declutter yeah decluttering oh gross
Cleaning Out My Closet clearing the
cabinets why would I want to spend time
doing that it feels like a waste of time
well it only feels like a waste of time
because you don't know what's on the
other side of the decluttering letting
go is merely the first step if you
pretend decluttering is the end result
you've missed the whole point clearing
the Clutter making room for what's truly
important so can you help them see
what's important without persuading them
without battering them with minimalism
because I tell you the best way to turn
them off from simplifying the best way
to turn them off from minimalism is to
prescribe minimalism to them yeah it's
yeah it's the and especially like trying
to Guilt Trip them I remember we were at
an event recently and uh there's a
little q a session and um a woman had
went up there and she was like you know
I went to Venice for this protest and it
was a very important uh protest it was a
very important subject
um all of my friends live in Venice and
you know they say that they care about
the same things that I do but I was the
only one there I didn't see anyone else
yeah right exactly and then they're like
what like what do I do when no one else
sees it and the the truth is is it
you have to stop caring what other
people see what matters is what you see
what matters is like how you feel and
are you uh are you doing what you need
to do to stay in honor with yourself
yeah and you weren't doing it for them
you were right you were doing it for
yourself at least that's what you're
telling yourself but your question there
that that person who's asking that
question actually was exposing something
about themselves oh I was doing this
because it looked good to be doing this
as opposed to I thought it was the right
thing for me to do absolutely and like
there might even be an aspect of
loneliness there too you know like I
felt lonely doing it and if that's the
case the good news is is there are
millions of people out there who like
and are interested in the same things
that you are that's right so if you feel
lonely in this uh Journey then find some
people who are on the same journey and
make some friends yeah you can even go
to minimalist.org we have 100 free local
meetup groups over there also an online
Meetup group as well yeah
minimalist.org we'll check in with the
patreon live stream in a moment in
Alabama but first real quick for right
here right now here's one thing one
rather exciting thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalists mark your
calendars y'all after 80 million views
and seven years on Netflix our first
film minimalism a documentary about the
important things which is directed by
our good friend Matthew Avella is coming
to YouTube this Sunday June 18 2023 so
please mark your calendars and sign up
for our email list will be 100
advertisement free you know we don't do
ads on our podcast or on our YouTube
channel you can check it out there we're
going to discuss much more next week
we'll dive deep into why we decided to
do this this is really the film's third
life in a way first life was in theaters
and then we did the Online release and
now it's going to be out there on
YouTube for millions of more people to
see if you sign up for our email list
over at the minimalists.com you will be
the first to get the link and I do want
to take a minute to mention some of the
amazing folks who were in this film I
just Ryan I just rewatched it I don't
want to get into the details because I
want to talk to you about it in detail
next week and my gosh it is an
outstanding film dude it's it's uh it's
one of those things where like I have to
look in the mirror and say hey Nicodemus
this might be the best creation you've
ever been part of yeah it's so good it's
it's a stunning film and we're going to
share it with you 100 advertisement free
for free on YouTube youtube.com the
minimalists I want to say thanks to some
fine folks here and we'll we'll expand
on this uh a bit next week but vve or we
as we call them they made the music for
the film and it the soundtrack is just
stunning they literally scored the whole
film for us
um all from scratch all from getting
like clips from Matt diavela you would
just send them clips and they're like
okay we the vibe you're going for yeah
and then they would create music I can't
tell you how many times I'll be playing
that album or songs from that album and
people are like oh my God who is this
why haven't I heard of this band yeah so
I said that with Drew I had lunch with
him last week Drew is the singer from it
so two two guys uh Nate pifer
and Andrew cliff and capener they formed
their own band called we or vve one of
them calls it we one of them calls it
vve so that's I love it right that's
great yeah and um so which one are you
are you we or vve okay I'll be vve then
all right
and so Nate is a Grammy nominated
producer and he is like the Godfather of
Provo Utah he runs these amazing Studios
out there super talented dude and then
he might have the best studio like this
side of the Mississippi man yeah I mean
it's like Dr Dre levels it's
unbelievable stunning yeah and uh I was
meeting with Drew uh the singer he's the
lead singer of my favorite band from my
favorite album parlorhawk and
um I couldn't believe we got them to do
the music for this film but I was
talking to him because he still he sings
to his kids every night so that's
awesome and I'm like do you like play
the old parlor Hawk songs he goes yeah
but the songs they like the most are
from both of your films yeah of course
dude that that was it was some special
music yeah it might be my favorite part
of uh both of those films is this are
the soundtracks yeah yeah and so uh
coming this Sunday June 18th minimalism
a documentary about the important things
which was sound mixed by our friend
Peter Duff post-production Peter as you
know him he mixes this podcast as well
color graded by our friend Chris Newhart
who was actually the Director of
Photography on the second film I want to
thank everyone in the film we'll do a
deep dive on it next week as well and of
course I want to thank Matthew Avella I
learned something about him this week
Ryan
but I'm gonna wait till next week I'm
gonna wait till next week's episode to
reveal something I learned about Matthew
Avella okay tune in for that let's uh
tune into our live stream right now
answer any questions you might have what
do you got in Alabama here's a question
from Catherine I feel like in the
pursuit of living a more intentional
life I try to be myself as much as
possible and that mindset is very far
from this intention how do you navigate
daily life being yourself while also
having to sometimes fake it till you
make it well that's another
disempowering story in fact there are
two disempowering stories here there's a
hidden one and there's one that's out in
the open yeah the first disempowering
story is that I have to fake it until I
make it who told you that who lied to
you
who told you that you can't be you now
here's the hidden story behind them well
I feel like I fake it until I make it a
lot do you want to pause here do you
want to yeah tell me about it so for me
it's like I might wake up uh in a bad
mood not feeling well
um you know like go grab a cup of green
tea I've been doing more tea than coffee
these days
um maybe you know wake up a little bit
but like I still feel bad still feel
maybe a little foggy and then I get a
phone call and I'm like oh man like I
really want to give this person the best
of me so in that sense I'm not faking it
because it is genuinely who I am but in
that moment I'm like so drained of
energy that like I am kind of Faking the
hey how's it going Ryan Nicodemus here
you know yeah would you consider that
faking it till you make it or I think
there are a distinction I would make and
I would just reframe or retitle the
story here yeah yeah I don't know that
you're faking it until you make it you
are doing what the best version of Ryan
Nicodemus would do right and which is
not faking it you're saying right and so
there is this story and love people use
things where there was a friend of mine
she said I'm gonna I'm gonna get one of
those wwjd bracelets so I can anytime I
go to the store and I feel compelled to
make an impulse purchase I can look down
and say what would Joshua do
and I would say I think I need one of
those as well not in the sense that like
what would Joshua Phil's Milburn do but
what would the best version of me do
yeah in the scenario that's not faking
it that's just behaving the way the best
version of myself would behave if I
followed myself around with a GoPro all
day what would the best of version of me
be doing right now I think that's a
beautiful question to ask would the best
version of me right now procrastinate
with the best version of me lie with the
best version of me
not do the work that is required to
create the meaningful thing that I want
to create what would the best version of
me do right now that's not Faking It
faking is being someone other than you
want to be you're pretending to be
someone else now here's the the second
part of the story for Catherine is you
are pretending this is the other
disempowering Story You're pretending
there is a fixed self oh yeah there is
no fixed selfie you can be whatever
version of you you want to be and so the
best version of Catherine now
um
it will be completely different from the
best version of you 10 years ago and the
best version of you 10 years from now
there is no fixed self because there is
no self at all we're talking today about
the false self that we create and that
is this identity that I am one complete
whole person that is unchanging well as
we've already explored the only thing
that is guaranteed is that level of
change man
I was gonna say Mariah and I we've been
asking each other
um
uh who who are you today a friend like
recommended us to Essence to each other
and I was like oh it's an interesting
experiment and the reason being is is uh
these old stories like carry through and
a lot of these old Stories We want to
drop so when we ask ourselves when we
ask each other that question and we're
describing ourselves
um if an old story is coming up like we
can call each other out on that like oh
that sounds like the old story you know
um that's about all I have because we've
only been doing it for a couple couple
few days but um yeah it's an interesting
concept like every morning waking up and
like looking in the mirror looking at
your partner and being like who are you
today oh I like that let's steal that
yeah let us know in the comments who are
you today and what would your answer be
to that question yeah we'll check back
in with the patreon live stream here in
a little bit but first i'm Alabama what
else you got for us here's a minimalist
Insight from one of our listeners
this is a listener tip for the attached
clothing episode
Jessica from Vermont this is your
neighbor Don from New Hampshire
I can definitely sympathize with your
struggles with New England weather
my solution was a three-in-one coat if I
zip out the inner lining I have a nice
fleece jacket for those cooler days
the water resistant outer shell makes a
nice raincoat or windbreaker
mine happens to have a hood built into
the collar which is great for snow wind
or rain
when I reassemble it I have a great
winter coat I've owned mine for 15 years
now and is the only coat I need
hope this tip helps you
and to Josh and Ryan please give them
Alabama more air time
her beautiful voice and cheerful and
nature always puts a smile on my face
perhaps you can add it to the lightning
round call it the malabama minute
thank you all for doing what you do
all right y'all that is our minimal
episode for today we'll see you on
patreon for the full two hour maximal
edition of episode 396 which includes
answers to a bunch more questions like
how do you unburden yourself from family
heirlooms that have been handed down for
Generations how do you keep a
multi-purpose space organized I love
extremely minimalistic spaces like jfm's
but I always wonder do these people have
hobbies
all that and a million more questions
for the minimalists also this week a
private minimalist home tour a
minimalist coffee shop with just a pop
of color well it's much much more of
less check out the minimalist private
podcast on patreon patreon.com the
minimalist remember you can try it for
free for a week and if you're still on
the fence here is a lovely testimonial
from one of our lovely patreon
supporters Shannon says I've been
listening to the public podcast for a
couple months and I've gotten so much
value from it that I just had to show my
support by signing up for the private
podcast which has helped me let go of so
many things which in turn has given me a
sense of relief and inner peace I can't
quite explain it but my home and life
feels lighter dude that is that is
awesome thank you Shannon thank you we
appreciate your testimonial if y'all
leave here today with just one message
please let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it
foreign
every little